draw your favorite Pokemon and bring
them to life with Pokemon art academies
learn to become a real Pokemon artist in
this new and exciting art academy start
with the basics
and evolved into a true Pokemon artist
with over 40 step-by-step lessons
anybody can learn to draw Pokemon
starting at the beginning you'll learn
simple techniques such as drawing lines
in adding color
made a mistake don't worry just use the
undo button and try again as you
progress you'll learn to drop Pokemon
from different angles
and how to compose your picture by using
basic shapes to create an outline
advanced lessons will teach you how to
add contrast to your art by using light
and shadows which leads into adding more
depth to your painting with the
free-flowing paintbrush before you know
it you'll be able to complete your very
own Pokemon masterpiece by using all the
skills you've learned from each lesson
the various tools that you can use in
Pokemon Art Academy will allow you to
draw in any style you want use the
pencil to create detailed sketches of
your Pokemon drawing with the outlined
pen allows you to create a new layer to
paint over and makes your Pokemon art
stand out the marker can add bright and
beautiful colors to your piece or if you
want to evolve your art try using the
paintbrush to add more depth and color
for a more realistic look pastels give a
nice natural soft edge to your Pokemon
drawing and blend colors together
airbrush your Pokemon for an incredible
finish
in free paint mode you can draw Pokemon
in any style you like letting you
express your inner Pokemon artists you
can unlock over 100 pictures of
different Pokemon to use as a guide and
develop your own unique style you can
even use the Nintendo 3ds cameras to
take photographs of your Pokemon
subjects to paint all of the pictures
you complete in lessons and in free
paint will be saved as cards in your own
album to view anytime you want send your
personal favorites to your friends or
post them to me verse and share the
experience become a true Pokemon artist
only with Pokemon art academy
you